ten years ago you could have guessed
that thy friends in a panda would
capture the hearts and attention of
millions but the dudes of dude perfect
have done just that even though their
internet-famous
not everyone knows the dudes behind the
perfect weather you're a hardcore fan or
just getting into the online antics of
dude perfect here's everything you need
to know Cory cotton published author not
content with mere internet stardom dude
perfect founding member Cory cotton is
also an author in 2011 Tyndale House
published his debut self-help book go
big make your shot count in the
connected world in it cotton charts the
course dude perfect took from being a
group of college kids to becoming
internet sensations he also provides
tips and pointers for other would-be
internet conquerors and if anyone knows
how it's these guys their charitable
dudes just because he's a young guy
riding a wave of internet millions don't
think cotton has let it all go to his
head he and the rest of the group have
made a point of giving back they've
aligned themselves with both charity
water and compassion international as
they all feel they should do something
more than provide entertainment as
cotton put it we have this platform and
we're always thinking of the best ways
to use it
charitable works are an excellent place
to start Cody Jones is a dad even in a
whirlwind of media activity the dudes
still make time for their personal lives
not only are three of the guys married
but in June 2016 Cody Jones took to
Twitter to announce the birth of his
daughter it's a good thing they inked
that TV deal with CMT because babies are
expensive and is throwing up in buckets
on cable TV pays for your kids college
fund so be it
their honorary globetrotters back in
2011 the guys in dude perfect began a
friendly rivalry with the original
trickshot masters the Harlem
Globetrotters the two teams met up at
the ranch for a game of course the dudes
managed to impress the Globetrotters
with their signature super large fishing
pole shot earning an invitation to
become a part of the team during their
2015 draft no word on whether or not the
dudes accepted the offer international
attention dude perfect attention isn't
limited to just the US the group's
tricks are so amazing that they've
caught the eyes
overseas outlets such as the Telegraph
in the UK in their article the Brits
question not only the authenticity of
the group's trick shots but they cast
doubt on the entire enterprise according
to the 2009 article the members of dude
perfect remain elusive
despite intense media interest sounds
like someone's upset they didn't get an
interview the authenticity debate became
so heated that the folks at Good Morning
America had experts look at some of the
videos to see if they were manipulated
are they real
are they fake we have computer analysts
looking at them predictably the experts
came up with nothing but that doesn't
mean the speculation has ended famous
fans the dudes have attracted an
impressive fan base including celebs
such as Tim McGraw Odell Beckham jr. and
Dale Earnhardt jr. all that's cool the
stars not only enjoy their videos but
have asked to appear in them even
everyone's favorite Ant Man Paul Rudd
wanted to take part in some of the fun
the secret of the Panda the identity of
the dude perfect Panda is one of the
biggest mysteries and entertainment well
okay one of the biggest mysteries on
YouTube there's some speculation that
it's an NYU student named Dorian Murray
who wears a panda suit to bring joy to
the people of New York but that's the
problem he's in New York and dude
perfect is based in Texas it looks like
the face behind the mask could be one of
those things that the public never
discovers like the Stig from top gear or
how Steven Seagal managed to keep a
perfect ponytail and all those early
nineties action movies expiration date
though they're having a good time now
the dudes eventually want to do other
things in June 2015
Tyler Toni told the kernel we don't want
to be 40 year olds on YouTube doing
basketball shots but don't worry it
doesn't mean they'll disappear from the
public eye entirely Toni went on to say
that he and the guys want to continue
entertaining just differently maybe they
can turn their attention toward training
the next generation of dude
perfectionist thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know what you want to know about dude
perfect